hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
Freddy's as you all may know and then
I've been told many times I need to go
back to the six night you guys have
basically been shouting at me to do it
so I'm gonna do it but I know that there
is not much different from this than the
last one other than that it is harder so
we're gonna have a lot tougher time
trying to get through this game with
everyone being a giant douche now I
don't know if there's any calls coming
in it looks like there's an O so I'm
just on my own for this game and they're
already out okay good so we're going
back into the same rhythm we usually had
before we just check regularly but I was
told that I actually need to check to
make sure that Freddy does not move from
his original position because that's
what really got me before I wasn't
checking to make sure that he didn't go
anywhere and other people said that I
needed to also check around to make sure
that they weren't there because someone
said that if you catch them on camera
that's actually gonna keep them from
always popping up at your door I don't
know if any of this is true this may be
just what you guys are trying to tell me
to get me to die quicker because I don't
know the rules it's like there's a
definite mix of signals going on from
the community here because everyone is
trying to figure out exactly what to do
and no one has a perfect idea of what
exactly to do everyone just dies
randomly and then they stick me in the
middle of this and I have to play the
game and you guys figure it out from
there but either way this is gonna be a
really tough to conserve power through
this last night because there's that
lovely music that I love there lovingly
loving music that loves me so much loves
me like a glove and above and above
but either way so long as I'm good about
my power I get to the point where
Freddy's outside my door now I think I
have to correct I think I have the
correct strategy about it in that you
need to be very conscious of your power
yes but you also need to be sure that
you're not having the doors down at all
time and I'm sorry I wasn't watching my
mouse has been acting up which is the
permit whatever you are visited by the
Grim Reaper and it wasn't actually a
skeleton underneath it was just Freddy
my own spit oh how are you already out
that's impossible you know what screw
you I don't even care I don't care that
you're the biggest Busan douche ally
I've got other problems like a ducky
that loves me too much you know what the
weird thing is people have already
started to draw rather nude drawings of
these animatronic creatures and I'm like
I know the Internet's a little messed up
place I've been here for a long time no
no it's not you
okay you're okay bun Ben is okay anyway
I know the Internet's a bit of a messed
up place come on - gotta be a little
nice than that I have not been focusing
very hard my friend it's good to see you
okay he's not coming is he
that's right Oh God not there it's got
to be very conscious god I need more
power I gotta hop up home you guys are
aggressive sons of [ __ ] you guys need
to take some relaxation therapy classes
get some scented candles
take a nice herbal bath smoke some weed
I don't care do something relax
Margaret is not condoning the smoking of
any herbal substances or anything for
that matter just don't don't don't do
that that against don't take advice in
general for me because I don't know what
I'm doing I mean look at me right here
I play the game that terrifies me for
the entertainment of others that's got
to be questionable life choices right
there boy
rude bastards you need to back off a
little bit because my brain is going a
million miles an hour you have no idea
what I'm gonna do when I get oh you
weren't there a second ago
okay then weirdo what a weirdo over
there am i right
yeah cool that's not a good sound Oh
does that mean that Freddie is starting
to get a little active maybe so far so
good fire code man not gonna be there
I'm gonna look at fire Cove and I'm a
walking run and flailing uselessly on my
door Oh looks like a bunch of useless
piece of ass over there banging on my
door layer douche nozzle what a [ __ ]
okay that duck is smart and apparently
to the Internet that duck is very sexy
to some people so nobody because and
I'll do me
we won't do each other probably I was a
good poem right there don't you haha me
oh he was good
don't you ha ha me let me Freddie
you stay down there okay so the basic
idea that I have for that every time you
have Freddie right there you can be
staring at the door and he won't come in
and if you ever want to look away and
check anything else you have to close
the door on him before that happens
so long as you're staring at it okay so
then you check everything else
everything else looks generally pretty
good then you go back I didn't check the
light before I turn that on he's gone
what a bunch of bull what a load of bull
everyone was lying to me well here we go
again it's gonna be fun in it all good
Chuckie already up cookie already out to
play down to bun buns also gone out bun
bun ponies dum dum da dum dum no one
likes you
dum dum you are dum dum but apparently
the story of this place is actually that
the place was shut down because some
dude in a bear costume of some sort at
least that's the story some suspect was
arrested and that's as far as I know but
some dude led five kids back into the
back room and then murdered them and
they could never find the body so they
were either stuffed inside these
costumes or who knows their souls left
and it affected everyone or Freddy eat
them or I don't know I don't know what
the bite of 87 is all about but people
are trying to come up with answers to
that no I just want to go about my life
get my overtime paycheck because for
some reason I decided 120 bucks no it
was
a week wasn't good enough for the 120 a
night that might be a little better but
God Ameen for this six-figure salary
wouldn't be good enough for this night
oh you thought already but that dokie
cuz that guy no time it don't even
matter if he comes running down I don't
care what a mic here well would I care
don't care nothing I ain't worried about
nothing where no no no worried about
nothing worry about nothing everything
is awesome everything is cool when
you're part of the team yeah everything
that's hardly fair I just missed him I
just looked over there I'm dead I'm dead
I might die but screw you I'm not good
at Google
solos got bad breath okay this sound I'm
actually gonna be focused so expect some
serious concentration going on here
because I am NOT going to lose this
I keep hearing footsteps every time I
put up the damn monitor it's like it's
intentionally dug every time I need to
do that it seeks it it's gonna go
creepy-crawly up my butt and no one's
gonna get to me no one's gonna touch my
butt okay he's already out he's just
saying hello that's totally fine I do
not know how I could go any quicker than
I am but I'm gonna have to try I guess
because this is bull this is a bull ass
ball here okay serious game face I'm not
fooling around here not fooling around
no no no ain't nobody fooling with me
they're out then it's every possibility
that they're gonna jump down my throat
so I'm gonna carefully watch very
carefully watch don't be spaz now nobody
got plenty of power I've done this a
million times
practically now and I can get through
this cuz I know I know the deal
worried about nothing hey let's be very
quick precise yeah yeah what now
what up doing it just as a check to kill
my ass gone already
Jesus how are you one bun man bun bun
man's been pretty tame ducky duck is
getting a little agitated I'm like an
angry duck to ruin your day
my [ __ ] huh huh god this is stressful
this is stressful for a different
reasons work discuss I know that they
could pop up at any moment and I
wouldn't have any time otherwise to
react already now they just pop up for a
few seconds that's it
have a check so spastically here oh my
god
slaw that Freddie I saw that looking at
me Oh Freddie got closer I saw that come
on come on Freddie what you got right
nope
that's what you're gone just gonna hair
you can stay doctor cool okay you're
gone now
that's okay all right cool Freddie still
in his hidey-hole pastic gotta be supers
buzzy still there
Freddie's looking at me pretty saw me
okay don't the dum-dum know you're still
there oh I'm going so fast out closer
exactly no give me my power back
dunno dum-dum you're still there hate
you hate you hate hate filled my life
with hate cut my life into pieces don't
show me in a suit I hate you to your
head right down to your glute or brand
new boots we even wear boots I don't
know your duckies and bears and bunnies
I don't know if you wear boots oh I hear
the warbles who's Laurel and who do I
visitors I wasn't ready
don't do that don't screw me up like
that son of a [ __ ] I will kill a bug
I'll squish it squish squish it squish
squish squish oh god pinecone man
finally out of his cage huh finally
decide to show himself not today don't
matter
goddamn goddamn oh come on click ha
losing it I'm losing it I'm losing it
I'm losing it I'm losing it god damn it
I'm losing it gotta keep up their
goddamn juggling act
did he leave was he still there I don't
know okay no no no come on oh you son of
a [ __ ] damn you can't do that
Vaughn already okay whoa this is
literally the worst I've ever had
oh my god I'm not just scared down super
stressed about doing this my hand is
cramping up from trying to be very very
precise about this keeping that door
down
it's 5:00 a.m. already I might just make
it gone yes he's gone okay pretty still
there
okay still good still good still
rock-solid still rock solid rock solid
rock solid rock solid rocks out hold you
wobble
okay who's wobbling he's got it he's got
it who's coming after me
okay the clock beat the clock be to
clock beat the clock beat the clock beat
the clock oh boy oh boy come on Volkers
no Freddie no Freddie no Freddie no
bunny go come on
goddamn it get over there okay don't
move don't move don't move don't move
don't move don't move don't move don't
move I didn't move that beginning didn't
key flannel lucky flail everybody lucky
flail tiresome over all that is justice
salting you dig back 50 cents 50 cents
yes Oh custom night Wow no way that's
the seventh night
it's no secret people don't mean that
there was a seventh night what is that
what is that what is that oh my god are
you kidding me there is no way there is
no frickin way I'm gonna set it to max
of course oh my god are you kidding me
I'm gonna die I'm so gonna die God are
you kidding me you can't say that I
didn't give it a try so let's give it an
old honest try yes ready is everybody
ready everybody in tight everybody in it
to win it but good good cuz I need you
flexible and I need you to believe in me
I need you to feel the energy that we
share together the group hug group hug
everybody group hug
bring it in I feel the love you want me
to die well you did that Jeremy Sally
Sarah Mike come on I gotta be like that
right from the get-go lock him down
ain't goin nowhere huh you ain't goin
nowhere
I'm looking at you yeah come on let's
see what you got I got I got a speed oh
they're all out already why didn't it
get a chance well that's not a good
sound give it one more go removed on me
just throwing that down just because
he's not even there what the [ __ ] is he
oh I don't like that oh my god I do not
like this only cancer okay he's there
okay oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh my god I don't even know how to
do that I literally can't check I have
to go by sound I think I think the only
way to win that game is to listen
instead of actually seeing
here the footsteps I hear them jingling
all over the hoagie he was there yeah
what the hell is that oh crap cut line
okay if this is how I died then I'm
gonna go out for blazing alright as soon
as he pops up here we go I think I
scared him off open the fists of fury
big strong man me all right so anyway
that is pretty much the end of that game
and the end of five nights at freddy's
this is probably my favorite horror game
of all time way up in the top ten it is
awesome in almost every way and like
seriously I can't even imagine because I
know there's been a problem with the
rendering with that static background it
makes my webcam all fuzzy but either way
just this has been absolutely awesome
and the developer has said he's already
working on a sequel so seriously thank
you so much a developer for making this
game and thank you all so much to the
community who is rallied around it it is
blown up big I really do appreciate all
the support that you guys have in me and
the new subscribers that have come in
thank you so much for giving me a chance
you're awesome
so thanks again everybody for watching
and check out the other scare games that
I played in the playlist right over
there
thanks again or in the description and
as always I will see you in the next
video